welcome back so today we're going to
talk about chapter 8 of the book tree
based methods for regression
classification
as we'll see the
their methods for supervised learning
would stratify or segment the predictor
space in order to make predictions
and they form what are called
decision trees in their
in their
stratification
and we'll talk about those methods which
are actually from the
they start in the mid 80s i'd say and
some of the names that associated with
that
well first of all the software package
was started in the method is called cart
for classification and regression trees
and the
the is the first two authors of cart are
leo brymen who was a
well-known statistician from berkeley
and jerry friedman who's our colleague
here at stanford
um
and friedman actually was one of our
teachers
in the 80s yeah back in 80s and trevor
and i were graduate students here and
that's when the the cot book came out
right and actually we're going to we
hope to talk to
jerry uh in this course i mean you'll
you'll get a chance to hear him talk
about the uh
the development of trees and how that
happened in the 80s so that's
uh the first part of the section is on
trees and then we'll talk about bagging
and boosting in random forests which are
which combine trees
in a more modern way it's interesting
because
trees were used widely for for a number
of years as as as one of the primary
learning tools and now trees are used
widely
as building blocks in some of the more
modern learning tools so they've been
around for a long time and they're going
to stay around
right so
a little more detail the the good side
of trees as you'll see they're simple in
a sense especially if they're small
and hence they can be useful for
interpretation but on the other hand uh
when you look at them as a supervised
learning techniques for prediction
they're definitely not competitive with
the best the best methods that around
but they can be made competitive uh when
they're combined in ensembles of trees
and we'll talk about that in the second
part of the lecture um
in particular bagging random force and
boosting and they were methods which
were developed in the in the 90s and
beyond which uh
improved the predict the prediction
performance of trees substantially
okay
so let's start at the beginning
the basic idea of a decision tree and
this applies to both regression and
classification we'll start with
regression and a little later we'll
consider classification
okay so
before we actually see a tree let's
think about how we would stratify some
data so here here's the the baseball
data
the response is salary and which we've
color coded
in this graph
from low
salary being blue and green
to higher salary being
yellow and red
for baseball players and each player has
we've measured two predictors number of
years he's been in the league in the
baseball league and
the number of hits he hits per season
okay so we want to predict uh salary
from those two predictors
so
if i asked you to stratify this
population i was trying to to separate
the high from low salary players what
would you do
well if you look at it looks like
the higher salaries are up here right
and the lower ones are maybe in this l
shape so one might think here's a place
you might you might say well let's split
around here
this uh this split separates the
predictor space into two regions right
the higher salaries we see some yellow
and red up here although it's mixed with
some blue and green and the lower ones
on the left all right so that does a
pretty good job of putting out the low
salary players on the left
doesn't do a great job on the right so
we might do a further split rob
so it looks like you've cut it five
years there so
years is number of years in the league
right now in the league yeah so yeah
which makes sense because the players
are in the league longer or you know can
expect to have a higher salary
whereas ones in the league lower have a
lower salary
but those with more years in the league
seem to be a bit mixed right they're a
bit mixed so
it looks like when our job isn't quite
done maybe we could do a
refinement by stratifying in this way
right
and now we have three regions we've got
we've got the high salary players up
here
and where what are these players these
are the ones who've been in the league
more than maybe around five years and
who have made more than maybe 125 hits
right they're the ones who have the
highest salary and then the medium
category looks like it's down here right
they've got
also more than roughly five years of
experience but fewer number of hits and
the lower is on the left
so with just two simple cuts you've made
a pretty good segmentation there exactly
and this is going to this is the idea of
a decision tree which will we'll uh
actually see on the next slide
when we applied a decision tree
technique to that data we got exactly
this tree and this tree is very much
like what i do in the previous slide
um and just
see on the next slide i've got the the
caption for this figure and throughout
the notes we have a detailed caption for
a lot of the figures i'm not going to
read out the caption in the course but
it's just there for your reference if
you want to
um
if you want us to uh to read the details
but
let's look at this tree and interpret
what it's saying and first of all i mean
what the layout is first of all so
this this is a series of splits at the
top we have we have all the data the top
and this year's lesson 4.5 is a split
it's a partition into
on the left
the players who are in the league for
less than 4.5 years on the right
players in the league for more than 4.5
years so this is pretty much the split
we saw
that i made here right
this split here is i said it five but
that's roughly a 4.5 is between four and
five so
this split at the top of the tree is the
partition
into the left and right regions
this tree says we're going to first of
all going to split players on the years
of experience those with more than fewer
than 4.5 years are assigned to the left
node
and those with more than 4.5 are
assigned to the right and what's that
number at the bottom remember yeah so
the number the bottom is the um
is the
i think the at the average log response
i think we took logs here so it's the
average log salary of the players who
fell into that bin
on the right
we do a further split on hits
among the players who have more than 4.5
years experience those who also have
fewer than 117.5 hits
are assigned to this branch otherwise to
this branch so we end up with three
three bins
from
highest salary medium salary and lowest
salary
and these are exactly the
well
almost exactly the three regions that i
drew here just by hand
okay
so here actually is the details the
partition that corresponds to that tree
and it's again very much like the one i
drew by hand the splits being given
there's the top split and here's the
split on the left but this was found by
an algorithm right it's followed by an
algorithm and actually the algorithm
we're going to describe is going to
build
a much larger tree and then it's going
to prune it from the bottom
to to give this three node tree
but so the automatic algorithm is going
to do what we looked looks it has to be
quite sensible in this example to divide
into three regions
okay some terminology which i've already
been using
uh the
the nodes at the bottom are called
terminal nodes because they're they're
the uh they're terminal they're not
further split you notice i'm calling
these trees but they're upside down
right the leaves
are the bottom right at the top it's
just for convenience
um the the non-terminal nodes are called
internal nodes which in this case are
the we have two and terminals and our
internal nodes in our tree but usually
the the uh the sorry internal nodes the
terminal nodes are the ones of interest
because they're the ones that describe
the partition of the predictor space
so how do we interpret that tree
well it's we split first on the years of
experience so that's saying the most
important factor is determining salary
is years of experience those with less
experience could have lower salary
on that left branch we didn't split any
further so it looks like the
the number of hits isn't important in
determining salary for the players less
experience but on the right where we
have the players with more experience
we've the hits is important right so
notice what we're saying here is that
this is not a symmetric tree right we
split
once to give us the left bucket but then
on the right we
uh we split again the the this bucket
into two more buckets and hit so the
point being that number of hits seems to
be important
for those with more more than 4.5 years
experience but not important for those
with fewer than 4.5
um
now again this gets the point that i
said earlier it's a very simple tree
which
makes it very it's very easy to display
and interpret right there's no equation
one thing that scares non-statistician
collaborators that we have it scares
them sometimes if they don't know much
math and you write an equation down for
a model
you know it's it's not very uh it's
intimidating not very attractive to them
one nice thing about a tree is that the
the tree is the model right this is the
summary of the model and we don't need
an equation to summarize it so it's
something as simple to understand by by
people who aren't comfortable with
mathematics
on the other hand it's probably much
simpler than it
it deserves to be right um
and for that reason
uh well for one of those reasons is it's
the the prediction error of trees is not
very good compared to other methods and
we'll see we can improve it
substantially if with combined
ensembles of trees
so i haven't said in detail how we
actually got that tree i said that that
the tree that we saw there actually
was very close to the one that we got
just by intuitively splitting the
the feature space but how does the
automatic tree tree growing algorithm
work
well the idea is we want to uh
divide the predictor space into
non-overlapping regions some some j
regions some number j
which we'll have to pick as well in the
case of the previous in that example j
was three
and having grown the tree the prediction
as we've seen just the average of the
response values that fall into each into
each of the terminal nodes
but how do we actually uh decide on the
splits on on the on the shape on the
the partition of the feature space well
if we thought um
in the most general way we could think
about trying to divide the feature space
in in the boxes
meaning that the edges of the regions
are parallel to the axes we want to do
that for interpretation right if we had
a region which was a circle it'd be
really hard to interpret predictive
space
but
even constraining ourselves into boxes
it turns out the
the the tree building process is is
difficult so let's let's pose exactly
the problem we want we might want to
solve
if we define our boxes as r1 through our
j for some number of boxes j
then we might want to find the the boxes
so that if we
sum up the variation
of the observations around the mean of
each box so
that the r j is the
set of observations falling in the jth
box
and y hat r j is the average of such of
the response of those observations so
those are the averages at the terminal
nodes in the tree right exactly so each
box represents one of those terminal
leafs right where you're going to
represent the observations by an average
yeah right and we have in this case a
j such terminal leaves and we're going
to choose a set of boxes that the total
variation of observations around their
mean in a box is as small as possible
that makes sense right because we want
the the box to be homogeneous
and to have observations which are very
similar in each box and across boxes
will be very different
so this looks like a reasonable way to
pose the box finding problem
but turns out actually that's too hard
to solve computationally if you say i
want to say find the
the 10 boxes that that
have the smallest value of this
criterion is actually computationally
infeasible about 10 might be solvable
but certainly beyond you know 10 20 or
50 it gets very hard especially if you
think about how many ways you can make
boxes
it's you know
the number just boggles it just gets big
very fast so exactly so trees use an
approximation sort of an obvious
method
top-down greedy approach
and it's top down because it starts at
the top with a whole set of observations
and then
uh
it splits them in into two pieces one at
a time at each level
it's greedy because it doesn't um find
the best split among on all possible
splits but only the best split at the
immediate place is looking
so let's go through the details of the
tree growing process
i've got on this slide but it might be
easier to go back to the
little tree we have there and just talk
through it there
so
what what we do is we talk we start at
the top with the full set of data
and all the predictors and we look for
the the predictor and the split that
produces the smallest criterion the one
we had written down which is the sum of
squares
of the response around
of each response around is the average
in the node so we're going to make a
split to produce two nodes
we'll look at all possible predictors
and all split points that produce the
smallest criterion value
so that's before we had three nodes here
so there'd just be a mean in the left
and the mean in the right exactly right
so we're starting with the full data
with actually with the only one node
we're going to split it into two and the
winner was this was the predictor years
at 4.5
producing these two branches the left
and the right and then the process is
repeated we look and we find the
the best split we can among the left and
right nodes and the winner was hits
at 117.5
so again each case we're doing the best
we can in a greedy sense and that
produced these three terminal nodes
okay
so let's go back to the
so i've said that in
much detail on this slide
and
then the question is
or one question is
when do we stop we could decide to stop
to just
do a small number of nodes like create
maybe three nodes like in that tree
or we could grow a larger tree